este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
surf shark vpn luego os doy más detalles
pero antes vamos con nuestra historia de
hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y si os dijera que la crisis del gas y
la guerra de ucrania pueden ser toda una
oportunidad única para españa y si os
dijera que españa podría convertirse en
el mayor distribuidor de gas natural de
toda europa no me vuelto loco es más ni
siquiera soy el único que lo piensa a
atentos
españa podría reemplazar a rusia a la
hora de convertirse en el mayor hub de
gas natural de la unión europea ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando sobre todo si sois
veteranos seguidores de visual político
tal vez este sea el primer vídeo que
hacemos en 6 años donde hablamos de
españa' para dar buenas noticias parecía
que siempre que algo va mal en todo el
mundo en españa irá peor sin embargo por
primera vez nos encontramos en una
crisis económica en europa donde los que
realmente están en apuros son los
alemanes y donde los europeos del sur
pueden ser la solución y diréis por qué
pues porque a diferencia de alemania
españa apenas compraba gas a rusia
[Música]
durante décadas el principal proveedor
de gas natural de españa era argelia sí
es cierto argelia también es uno de esos
países donde los derechos humanos son
opcionales pero tiene una ventaja no son
rusia y tienen gas natural no sólo eso
españa es el país mejor preparado para
recibir ese gas natural licuado que
viene de países como eeuu o qatar para
que os hagáis una idea el 27 por ciento
de la capacidad de regasificadora de
toda europa está en suelo español dicho
de otra forma que bastaría con construir
un gasoducto que conectará a españa con
francia y el resto de europa y madrid se
estaría convirtiendo en el epicentro de
todo el mercado del gas europeo una
fantástico verdad pues si eso sería lo
lógico si el mundo fuera lógico sin
embargo la realidad es esta otra rusia
es el segundo suministrador de gas de
españa porque caen los flujos de argelia
vale vamos a ser honestos esta noticia
tiene trampa es decir no es face news
pero si podemos decir que es una media
verdad en este caso nuestros amigos de
bloomberg han caído un poquito en el
click bait porque lo veremos al final
del vídeo
pero lo que sí es cierto de este titular
es que en el momento en el que españa
podría ser la gran salvadora de europa
una serie de catastróficas decisiones
han llevado a que no lo sea decisiones
que están llevando a comprar más gas
ruso en algunos momentos que antes
incluso de la guerra y diréis pero
porque qué sentido tiene la respuesta
está en una palabra marruecos y diréis
mira que tiene que ver marruecos en toda
esta historia al final del vídeo lo
entenderéis yo os aviso y de antemano
olvida todo lo que sabéis sobre economía
y toma de decisiones racional porque la
historia de hoy está llena de facebook
así que la pregunta que nos hacemos es
porque españa está comprando gas ruso
porque argelia no quiere hacer una
fortuna vendiendo gas a toda europa a
través de españa de verdad españa podría
llegar a convertirse algún día en ese
hub de gas natural hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes antes de
hablar de la seguridad en el suministro
del gas natural vamos a hablar de la
seguridad en internet ya lo sabéis todos
estaréis cansados de haberlo oído las
vpn son la solución ideal para navegar
por internet de forma libre y segura
libre porque nos permite entrar en
páginas webs restringidas en nuestro
país y segura porque nos protege de
todos esos hackers cookies innecesarias
y virus que hay por ahí en internet y
cuál es la vpn favorita de visual
político exacto sur shark vpn creedme el
tema de la ciberseguridad se lo toma muy
pero que muy en serio por ejemplo sur
shark tiene una herramienta que se llama
clean web que bloquea todos los popups
de propaganda por donde se cuela en un
montón de bots y de cookies que
francamente no queremos tener en ninguno
de nuestros dispositivos pero además por
si todo esto fuera poco con una única
cuenta de surf vpn podrás registrar
todos los dispositivos que quieras
quieres navegar con seguridad desde tu
smart view o desde tu teléfono móvil o
desde tu ordenador desde tu tablet da
igual puedes hacer todo esto con una
única cuenta de surf shark vpn y por
supuesto tenemos una oferta especial
para todos vosotros que seguís visual
política básicamente si utilizáis el
código político terminado en ca podréis
disfrutar de 183 por ciento de descuento
más tres meses extra totalmente
gratuitos tenéis todos los enlaces en la
descripción no esperéis más que ya sé
que muchas veces dejamos pasar estas
cosas y cuando nos queremos dar cuenta
ya es demasiado tarde así que entrar ya
en la página web y descargaros ya la
aplicación y ahora sí vamos a ver un
poco de historia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
marruecos el vecino incómodo
para atender esta historia tenemos que
remontarnos muy atrás en el tiempo
concretamente nos tenemos que ir al 4 de
julio de 1776 y diréis qué pasó ese día
y tt
[Música]
el 4 de julio de 1776 las 13 colonias
que justo después formarían los estados
unidos de américa firmaron su
independencia del reino unido- y sabéis
qué marruecos fue el primer país del
mundo en reconocer esta independencia de
hecho en 1787 cuando eeuu ni siquiera
había redactado su constitución
marruecos fue el primer país en
reconocerles como nación soberana dicho
de otra forma rabat es el aliado más
antiguo de washington tiene una amistad
de más de 200 años
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
pero marruecos no era una colonia pues
sí y no a finales del siglo dieciocho
marruecos era una monarquía pero a
finales del siglo 19 francia y españa lo
invadieron y lo convirtieron en un
protectorado
embargo en el año 1956 marruecos volvió
a ser independiente y volvió al poder la
dinastía alauí en otras palabras que
marruecos es una monarquía aliado y
occidente aliada de estados unidos y
hasta aliada de israel es una democracia
por supuesto que no pero es un buen
aliado en una zona donde hacen falta
muchos aliados si quieres combatir el
terrorismo islámico en el norte de
áfrica tener a marruecos a tu lado es
una ayuda muy pero que muy importante y
eso explica que en todas las disputas
con españa la mayor parte de los países
occidentales incluido eeuu se pongan de
perfil pero de eso hablaremos más
adelante porque ahora la pregunta que
muchos estaréis haciendo es y quién es
el mayor enemigo de marruecos son sus
anteriores colonos francia y españa-
pues no nada de eso atentos
argelia la rusia del norte de áfrica
argelia y marruecos tienen muchísimas
cosas en común ambos son países de
mayoría musulmana ambos han sido
colonias francesas e incluso ambos
países se ayudaron mutuamente para
lograr la independencia sin embargo tan
pronto lograron quitarse el yugo
colonial empezaron los problemas en 1963
cuando la argelia independiente tenía
solo 4 años estalló una guerra con
marruecos por disputas territoriales
desde entonces estos dos países no han
enterrado nunca el hacha de guerra
pensando bien párrocos es una monarquía
pro occidental mientras que argelia es
una república de socialismo árabe y
diréis qué es eso del socialismo árabe y
seis veteranos seguidores de visual
polític no os lo habréis oído mencionar
mil y una veces y sois nuevos en este
canal tranquilos que os hago un resumen
por cierto que si sois nuevo suscribiros
y de duda la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones
recordad que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas y que también por cierto no
os podéis apoyar en patrón pero sigamos
con la historia
pues bien el socialismo árabe es un
cóctel ideológico que fue muy popular en
muchos países musulmanes podríamos
definirlo con tres claves laicismo
militarismo y culto al líder en el caso
de argelia más que un líder concreto
deberíamos hablar del llamado le pouvoir
es decir el poder son un grupo de
militares principalmente que controlan
todos los resortes políticos y
económicos del país para que os hagáis
una idea mientras marruecos ha llegado a
tener incluso bases militares de eeuu
argelia ha recibido a gente como el che
guevara y ha tenido toda clase de
acuerdos con la antigua unión soviética
y diréis vale pero más allá de las
ideologías porque discuten tanto estos
dos países pues principalmente por
disputas territoriales y principalmente
la disputa por un territorio muy
concreto el sáhara occidental'
[Música]
hablamos de un territorio que está en
pleno desierto del sahara por aquí solo
viven alrededor de quinientas mil
personas sin embargo marruecos defiende
a machamartillo que eso es una región
más dentro de su país hecho el 80% del
territorio del sahara occidental está
controlado de facto por marruecos
argelia sin embargo apoya la
independencia del sáhara este conflicto
lleva sobre la mesa desde los años 60 si
os interesa este tema tenemos un vídeo
en visual político donde lo cubrimos con
más detalle pero hoy vamos a pasar un
poco de puntillas por ello porque lo
importante en la historia de hoy es que
marruecos y argelia se llevan muy mal
cada vez peor de hecho en 2021 tres
caminos argelinos fueron atacados en el
sáhara occidental y desde entonces estos
dos países están prácticamente al borde
de la guerra más concretamente desde
septiembre de 2021 argelia y marruecos
han cortado todas sus relaciones
diplomáticas y quedamos con la fecha
septiembre de 2021 porque va a ser muy
importante más adelante y por supuesto
el fin de estas relaciones diplomáticas
también se traduce en que argelia ha
dejado de venderle gas a marruecos y ya
sé lo que estaréis pensando vale fonseca
todo esto está muy bien pero y qué pinta
españa en todo esto pues tranquilos
porque ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
qué pinta españa en todo esto
durante décadas argelia ha sido el
principal proveedor de gas natural a
españa de hecho españa ni siquiera tiene
gasoductos que la conectan con rusia
atentos a este mapa
[Música]
por un lado tenéis este gasoducto que
veis aquí que se llama el magreb europa
se empezó a construir en los años 60 y
pasa por marruecos tiene capacidad para
12 veces os acordáis de las veces si
recordáis las veces m of millions of two
beach meters es una de las principales
formas de medir el gas natural aquí en
lugar de barriles usamos bcm es pues
bien para que os hagáis una idea el
consumo total de gas natural de españa
es de alrededor de 34 bcm pues bien este
caso ducto transportado cbc m es como
pasa por marruecos rabat se quedaba con
un 7 por ciento del gas como pago por
royalties el problema porque desde
septiembre de 2021 argelia ha acortado
todas sus relaciones con marruecos y por
eso en 2021 argelia corto el tránsito de
gas de este gasoducto así que marruecos
perdió todos sus derechos de tránsito
pero no pasa nada porque argelia todavía
puede seguir suministrando españa a
través de otro gasoducto del cual
hablamos pues del medgaz
este caso ducto tiene capacidad de 10
bcm y conecta directamente españa con
argelia dicho de otra manera diez veces
más 12 bcm son 22 bcm es decir más del
60 por ciento de las necesidades de gas
de españa y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos entonces es argelia la
rusia de españa pues no exactamente
porque a diferencia de alemania españa
se ha cuidado la diversidad del
suministro por eso a diferencia de
alemania españa sí tiene plantas
regasificadoras de gas natural licuado
pero de eso vamos a hablar más adelante
y diréis entonces con quién tiene
problemas españa pues con marruecos
podríamos decir que marruecos es un gran
amigo de occidente pero desde luego no
es tan buen amigo de españa por supuesto
madrid siempre ha apoyado la
independencia del sáhara occidental pero
no sólo eso las disputas por las zonas
pesqueras entre ambos países son norma
habitual
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea españa y
marruecos han llegado a tener su versión
baja en calorías del conflicto de las
malvinas si habéis oído bien esto
ocurrió en el año 2002 a marruecos no se
le ocurrió nada mejor que invadir el
islote de perejil y diréis que es el
islote de perejil pues es una isla
deshabitada con nulo interés estratégico
en este caso españa mandó al ejército en
una operación rápida echaron a los
marroquíes
[Música]
y diréis interés tenía marruecos en
invadir un islote deshabitado pues
yo creo que nadie lo sabe yo os he dicho
que en esta historia apenas hay una
lógica racional y no la podemos buscar
sin embargo lo que sí tiene mucho
interés son estas dos ciudades atentos
al mapa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
lo que veis aquí es ceuta y melilla y si
estos son dos ciudades españolas en la
costa marroquí marruecos considera que
son colonias que deberían de ser parte
de su territorio el problema el problema
es que ceuta y melilla no son colonias
son dos ciudades tan españolas como
puede ser madrid o sevilla sus
habitantes votan en las elecciones
tienen los mismos derechos que el resto
y pagan impuestos como cualquier otro
español sin embargo marruecos no piensa
igual y no sólo hablamos de palabras
sino de hechos recordáis aquel vídeo
donde os contábamos como bielorrusia
envió a inmigrantes sirios a la frontera
con lituania pues podríamos decir que
los pioneros en el antiguo arte de
utilizar inmigrantes como arma política
fueron los marroquíes atentos miles de
migrantes asaltan la barrera en la
frontera de españa con marruecos pero no
sólo eso más rotos también amenaza con
aislar comercialmente a ceuta y melilla
y esto ya son palabras mayores sin
embargo no todo es blanco o negro sí es
cierto las relaciones diplomáticas entre
españa y marruecos son complicadas por
no decir otra cosa peor sin embargo hay
dos matices importantes que tenemos que
señalar
recordáis que marruecos tiene esa
relación especial con eeuu eso significa
que madrid no puede romper lazos con
rabat así como así no sólo eso además
aunque los lazos diplomáticos sean
complicados por no decir otra cosa peor
los lazos comerciales no podían ser más
intensos y ya sé lo que pensáis algunos
sobre todo los que veáis este vídeo
desde españa venga allá fonseca de
verdad hay tanto comercio con marruecos
pues os voy a dar un ejemplo
inditex inite que es la empresa de moda
más grande de toda españa y una de las
más grandes de todo el mundo y es el
grupo donde por ejemplo está sara pues
bien inditex tiene 30.000 puestos de
trabajo en tánger marruecos y esto es
sólo un ejemplo más en cierto modo
marruecos es a españa lo que méxico es a
los eeuu
pero ya sé lo que estáis preguntando
todos en este momento lo va a ver
fonseca vale muy bien llevamos 10
minutos de vídeo nos acabas de soltar
una parrafada sobre un montón de países
pero y qué tiene que ver todo esto con
el gas natural es tranquilos porque
ahora es cuando llegue a la parte
realmente interesante del vídeo el plot
twist que nadie se esperaba atentos
el plot triste definitivo
a diferencia de muchos otros países
europeos casi todo el gas que consume
españa viene por barcos para que os
hagáis una idea en julio de este año
2022 el 72% del gas natural que se
compró era gas natural licuado sólo el
28 por ciento venía de gasoductos
principalmente de argelia y diréis i
stop que significa pues básicamente
hasta la guerra de ucrania los españoles
pagaban mucho más por el gas que por
ejemplo los alemanes ahora bien españa
tiene un suministro mucho más
diversificado y por tanto mucho más
seguro atentos a este gráfico
aquí podéis ver los principales
proveedores de gas natural de españa
fijaos en la línea de argelia veis que
hay un punto muy concreto donde
suministra empieza a bajar qué momento
es ese exacto septiembre del año 2021 el
momento en el que argelia cortas
relaciones con marruecos en ese momento
cortaron también todo el gas que iba por
el gasoducto magreb europa sin embargo
no hay problema porque como veis españa
no tardó mucho en encontrar otro gran
proveedor eeuu de hecho desde el año
2022 eeuu se ha convertido con
diferencia en el principal exportador de
gas natural a españa y aquí es donde
vamos a la noticia que decíamos al
principio veis algo más en esta gráfica
vamos a volverla a poner exacto
concretamente en el mes de junio de 2022
rusia llegó a ser el segundo proveedor
de gas natural a españa esto es algo
preocupante pues sí es preocupante
significa que ahora españa ha ya
sustituir a argelia por rusia pues no
por supuesto que no de hecho si os
fijáis en la misma gráfica veréis que
españa depende más de países como
nigeria que de la mismísima madre rusia
ahora bien dónde está el problema pues
el problema es el coste de oportunidad
en un momento donde media europa quiere
dejar de comprar gas a rusia españa
podría jugar un papel fundamental
bastaría con construir un gasoducto que
conecta españa con francia para así
poder revender el gas natural licuado
procedente del resto del mundo y sobre
todo el gas argelino que sería mucho más
barato este suministro podría llegar
hasta la mismísima alemania y si lo
sabemos esto no es algo fácil y llevaría
varios años pero el proyecto está sobre
la mesa y aunque francia no lo quiera el
resto de europa lo está deseando de
hecho hasta tiene un nombre el midcat
solo hace falta financiación europea y
un poquito de tiempo
[Música]
entendéis el plan tiene lógica verdad
sin embargo ya podéis ver como las
importaciones de argelia están cayendo y
diréis porque ya hemos visto que argelia
y marruecos se llevan a matar pero que
pinta españa en toda esta enemistad pues
aquí es donde llega el plot twist
definitivo atentos
sánchez ratifica su apoyo a la propuesta
marroquí sobre sáhara y podemos la acusa
de seguir la estela de trump
habéis oído bien en un giro copernicano
inesperado de los acontecimientos el
gobierno de españa' de repente ha
decidido acercarse a marruecos ya
alejarse de argelia y si yo he hecho en
el crítico momento en el que todo el
mundo quiere llevarse bien con argelia
[Música]
por supuesto que españa no es el único
ni el primer país en reconocer que el
sáhara es marroquí ya lo hizo eeuu en
2020 con la presidencia de donald trump
y alguno pensará pues es que seguro que
españa tendrá un gobierno muy de
derechas muy trampa no que ha querido
seguir la estela de washington en la
época de trump pues nada de eso el
gobierno de españa' en este momento es
una coalición de socialdemócratas con
extrema izquierda dicho de otra forma
que desde luego no hay ninguna
justificación económica para este
movimiento pero tampoco ideológica
diréis seguridad nacional pues lo cierto
es que tampoco por supuesto que a españa
le interesa normalizar sus relaciones
con marruecos pero al darles el sáhara
occidental' han regalado su mayor baza
de negociación pero no sólo eso además
que españa no solo se ha puesto del lado
de marruecos en la contienda del sáhara
es que han llegado muchísimo más lejos
atentos españa empieza a abastecer de
gas natural a marruecos a través del
tubo que corto argelia le veis la lógica
pues yo tampoco
ahora que toda europa está dispuesta a
comprar gas de cualquier lado que no sea
rusia-españa le está dando prioridad a
las ventas a marruecos incluso a costa
de tener que comprar gas más caro para
ella misma como os podéis imaginar todo
esto tiene consecuencias por ejemplo las
relaciones con argelia están en su peor
momento y no se trata sólo de una
cuestión diplomática las ventas de gas
de españa marruecos también están
haciendo que argelia frene el suministro
[Música]
podéis imaginar los argelinos no quieren
venderle mucho gas a españa para que
luego termine en manos de su
archienemigo conclusión están reduciendo
el flujo que llega a españa y grace pero
vamos a ver de verdad los argelinos
están tan dispuestos a dejar de ganar
dinero vendiendo su gas tranquilos
tranquilos porque en estos momentos a
argelia los compradores les sobra italia
firmó un acuerdo de energía con argelia
en una apuesta para evitar a rusia dicho
de otra forma que españa ha dejado pasar
una oportunidad mientras que italia la
está aprovechando al máximo así que
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
creéis que es posible revertir esta
decisión puede españa negociar nuevas
condiciones para comprar gas con argelia
de verdad es posible que españa a pesar
de todo esto consiga convertirse en el
hub del gas natural europeo podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que aquí en visual político sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribimos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto
[Música]